[Aplausos]
y Florida plantea una nueva restricción
a los conocimientos que pueden enseñarse
en las escuelas públicas la mayoría
republicana del Estado impulsa una ley
que prohibiría hablar de educación
sexual antes de sexto grado Es decir
para los alumnos menores de 12 años
entre los contenidos censurados estaría
la pedagogía sobre las enfermedades de
transmisión sexual o la menstruación
opositores a la ley ya han denunciado la
reducción de la diversidad de la
educación pública y han bautizado el
texto como Don save period no digas
periodo en analogía la legislación
conocida como Don say gay que prohíbe la
educación sobre género y orientación
sexual iniciativas apoyadas por el
gobernador ultraconservador de Florida y
precandidato presidencial recordemos ron
de santis para hablar del caso Contamos
con Paula Ávila Guillén directora
ejecutiva del women's Center y abogada
en derechos humanos Paola bienvenida a
France 24 le quiero comentar si ronde
santings firma el texto la ley entraría
en vigor el próximo 1 de Julio
exactamente que implicaciones tendría
para el sistema educativo público la
aplicación de esta normativa que como
veníamos diciendo impide que en las
escuelas se hable por ejemplo de
menstruación antes de los 12 años
Pues realmente es una ley alta
preocupante porque es una ley que no
solo va a restringir la educación sexual
que es funda fundamental para la
embarazo temprano para la prevención de
enfermedades transmisión sexual pero
adicionalmente la educación sexual entre
etapas tempranas es fundamental para la
prevención de abuso infantil niños y
niñas que se sienten cómodos con sus
cuerpos saben qué tipo de contacto es
apropiado Y qué tipo de contacto no es
pueden decirle a un adulto responsable
cuando están siendo abusados entonces
Esto va a tener definitivamente
consecuencias devastadoras para toda una
infancia y para esa infancia que
eventualmente se vuelve adolescencia y
adultez bueno está hablando usted de Un
ejemplo muy importante en caso de
posibles abusos y me surge la duda Cuál
es el posible miedo o el tabú para los
republicanos al hablar sobre género
sexualidad o menstruación en la escuela
Esto no se trata de ningún miedo yo yo
creo firmemente que este tipo de leyes
son leyes que están siendo pasadas por
una necesidad de imponer una visión en
el mundo en donde principalmente las
mujeres a las niñas tenemos un rol
secundario debemos ser controladas por
por este sistema autoritario
tradicionalmente porque nos están usando
como fichas en un juego político
este tipo de leyes están haciendo
pasadas por por parte de
una
al medio de una campaña presidente
Tratando de buscar este tipo de
reconocimiento a nivel nacional y
mientras tanto no le importan Cuántas
niñas y personas pueden ser afectadas
por por este tipo de leyes o sea estamos
siendo usados en medio de una guerra
política de una forma que es realmente
deshumanizada pues se me ha adelantado
usted a la próxima pregunta precisamente
sobre esa deshumanización sobre la
acogida que puede tener a nivel nacional
dentro de una carrera para la elección
de 2024 frente a Donald Trump en el
partido republicano que parece que va a
ir por esta línea ultraconservadora pero
que acogida Real puede tener esto entre
el gran público estadounidense entre los
votantes republicanos desde luego que
son a los que a priori podrían votar a
ronde sandwich
Pues en realidad lo que hemos visto
recientemente con por ejemplo las
votaciones que se hicieron dieron
en contra de las penalizaciones
absolutas del aborto en algunos estados
la elección reciente de una juez Pero
derecho reproductivo
en contra que los votantes no están a
favor de estas intervenciones del estado
es irónico que uno de los partidos
conservadores no quiere intervenciones
del estado en la vida privada es parte
de su base política pues esté tomando
unos pasos tan largos de intervenciones
el estado intervenciones En qué pueden
leer los niños intervenciones En qué
pueden hacer o no hacer los niños
intervenciones en qué puede hacer uno en
su vida privada y realmente yo creo que
todas las encuestas lo dicen y lo que
nosotros hemos visto Es que la mayoría
de personas en Estados Unidos no está de
acuerdo con este tipo de intervenciones
arbitrarias en la vida de las familias
de los individuos pensiones del estado
en cómo y qué se debe educar a sus hijos
y vamos con otro tema también muy
relacionado Y es que las organizaciones
por derechos lgbt defienden también que
dentro de la educación pues haya ese
tipo de Educación dirigida a personas
que se sientan representadas con otro
tipo de sexualidad como afecta la
ausencia de educación sexual en términos
de discriminación hacia otros o de falta
de aceptación hacia uno mismo si uno se
reconoce por ejemplo como persona no
heteronormativa
Mira las estadísticas nos muestran que
cuando no existe educación de género con
enfoque de género el bullying de los
niños sube tenemos niños que se sienten
más deprimidos tenemos altas tasas de
suicidio en la adolescencia
temprana como
y resultados que no exista una educación
que sea lo suficientemente inclusiva que
permita a los niños a las niñas ser ser
quien ellos son pero que trata de
imponer una visión que no corresponde a
como ellos se sienten identificados y
esto realmente es problemático es
problemático porque es claro evidencia
demostrado que la educación sexual
bullying reduce la afectación mental en
los niños y en los adolescentes para que
puedan tener una vida que sea sana y
saludable no solo Físicamente pero
adicionalmente mentalmente entonces un
efecto realmente devastador
Especialmente cuando ya existe evidencia
que demuestra que si se tiene un
currículum inclusivo que hable sobre
género le sobre inclusión se reduce
drama dramáticamente los efectos de
Salud Mental en en niños y niñas que
Sencillamente no se consideran a sí
mismos como heteronorma tivos y abriendo
un poco el foco hacia el partido
demócrata hacia el actual gobierno de
Joe biden se están haciendo algún tipo
de políticas para ahondar para poder
ayudar en este problema social que usted
nos habla y es la salud mental de los
niños y el aumento de la tasa de
suicidios
Mira yo creo que este es un tema que no
le pertenece a los partidos le pertenece
Sencillamente a los Estados los estados
deberían preocuparse en general
independiente de cuál es su posición
política cuando existe un problema de
Salud Mental en niños y niñas cuando
existe un problema de bullying en los
Colegios cuando existen unas tasas de
abuso sexual alto cuando existen unas
tasas de embarazo temprano alto que
puede ser prevenible entonces hay
medidas que se están tomando pero las
medidas Sencillamente no son suficientes
si van a depender de el nivel Estatal si
van a depender de quién está a cargo
políticamente de este estado por eso es
que es absolutamente importante que
existan leyes federales que sean
mandatorias a nivel de todo el estado de
una educación sexual laica educación
sexual basada en ciencia Y una educación
sexual
y de género que ayude a nuestros niños
en hacer felices
hacer lo mejor que ellos puedan ser